あなたは
なぜ学ぶのですか
この問いがもし皆さんに与えられた時皆さんだったらどういう答えを返してシュッ
僕は今高校2年生です学校という場所に通っています
なので周りの同級生とか後輩とか先輩にこの質問を引いてみるです
そうすると
いい大学に行かないといけないとかなんかみんながやってるからとか
なんとな赤手にとりたくないしみたいな
なんていうのかなとっても自動的で何か後ろ向きな答えがたくさん書いてきたんです
そんなにもかかわらずみんな一生懸命勉強してるんですね
実は今ぼく期末試験の真っ最中で明日も支援があるのですがこんなところにいますね
はい今たぶん僕の学校の人はたぶんみんな勉強してるんだと思うんですけどこんな
ところで触れずになっていますそれで
だけどその寝るなもう森林が勉強する
なんでやりたくもないことをやるんだろうなと思っ
そこまでして学ぶ視聴あるのかなって僕は思ってしまった
それで僕は中学時代から年か人と一緒にイベントしたいとか様々なことをしてきました
そういうことが自分にとって楽しいことだったし周りに逝かすのような存在だったん
です
好きなことばっかりする毎日を送っていました勉強というもので全しなかったんです
そんな生活をしているので当然
親からはあんたそんなことばかりしないで勉強しなさいと言う多分これ日本中の
お母さんが子どもに言うセリフランキングナンバーワンだと僕は思っているんですけど
こんなことを親に言われてそれでも僕はその親の忠告を無視し続けその結果
これでございます
はいいわゆる赤点というものですね
で僕はクラスで最下位で撮りました
赤点ですびっくりする準備を撮りました
単位を落とすよ君っていう脅しを受けました
敗訴したもう後がここやめるのかなってこと思ったんです
そしたらもう就職できないのかな俺と思っ
そしたらもう人生終わってしまうかなーと思って
すっげー勉強っていうものが恐怖になったんです
同時に
自分
なんで学ぶんだろうな
ってことを
考えます
でも自分でその答えというのはできませんでした
そこで僕はいろんな学校高校生を集めて
自分たちが何で学ぶのかっていうのを
考えてみればいいんじゃないかってことを思いついたんです
それで作ったのがこの方向性教室って場所です
ここ何やってるかというと高校生が高校生に授業をやっています
で授業って言ってもがちな授業です
英語とか数学とか古文とかいわゆる学校の教科としてある授業をガチでやってます
ただ同じ高校生という立場です
教えるのも受ける授業を受けるのも航行するそれを生かして一方で弾い知識を
押し付けるんじゃなくて
例えばグループでマナビアということだったり
必ず授業が終わった後は授業をした人
授業を受けた人全員が一緒になって振り返る振り返りをするっていうそういった活動を
しています
それでこういった活動をしているうちに
なんていうのかな
勉強って
五大東
同じ立場の方向性同じ立場に教えてもらうと意外とにもなんかもしれないなあという
こと国を持ってきたんです
教科ごとで考えると例えば数学めっちゃすね死とか
国語めっちゃすぎないですと彼が自分にすごくてこの楽しんだよっている
このいい数分解を見るとワクワクするんだよっていう最初教師悪いなって思ったんです
けどそんなことを僕に教えてく
そういうのを見ているうちに実際勉強って楽しいのかもなってことを思い始め
でよく考えたら自分も社会に重用し山に行っていたんです
この写真なんかねあの塾の先生みたいだということでいつも言われるんですけど僕は
高校2年生ですので間違いないよしてくださいはいそれで僕は社会が好きです
愛知リが特に好きなんですが地図ってものがある
ます
地図というものは
伊能忠敬とかよく出てきますけれど
人類がやっぱり生活をもっと良くするために作っていくものなんです
そのために開発して生み出したものなんですけど
ビザが糞って全部そうで何で学問というものがあるかというと人間がもっと生活をより
よくするために
初 a を示しているものっていうのが学問なんですね
はい僕はそのことに気づきました
で
もともとはその
チラッたはずなんですみんな勉強ってものが楽しくないものじゃなくて
きっとワクワクしてたのだってが不問っていうのは今入ったみたいに本当は人間の生活
をもっと良くするためのものであって人間を恐怖に陥れるものじゃないはずです
でもともとは幼稚園とか小学校にとって違ったはずで
例えば小学1年生の時ちょうど5月とか6月ぐらいですかね
初めて宿題ってものが学校の先生から出されたと思います
ひらがなの練習をしてこいとか足し算をやってこいとかそういうプリントとかが配られ
た
たぶんきっと皆さんワクワクしてたんです
お家へ帰って連絡道と親に見せて恐縮だが出たんだよって言って行き来しながら報告し
て一目散に取り組んでいたはずだんですただそれが残念なことに
歳をとって
親とか
単位だねテストとかそういったものによって
恐怖によって学びってものが支配されるようになっちゃう
そういう状況があると思います
でも
もうなんかに行ってるんですけど学問っていうのは人間が生活をもっと良くするたび
作ったものが春はず手を添えることはないはずです
絶対本当は自分を劇にするものじゃなくて味方になるもののはずなんですよね
で僕はやっとそのことに気づきました高校1年生して
でちょっと頑張るんですよ
でただこれは気をつけないといけないのは上に際し最高さと書いてあるということです
ね
だから僕はもう危うく単位落としてあげたんですけれどもそ寸前のところで言って僕は
やっと気付きます
それでいい
やっと自分ってなぜ学ぶのだろうっていうことに対して
何度も言ってるその抱く者というものが
救ってくれるもの
人間が自分の生活をよりよくするためにある物っていうことを考えてやっぱり自分が
学んでその学んだことを生かしてもっと世界の役に立ちたいなとか
世界を洗いたいなということを考えるようになったんです
でもなんかすげー来前向きなのはいいんですけど
また抽象的だなと思っ
もうちょっと具体的に話をします
そうするとやっぱり最初の問い
あなたはなぜ学ぶでしたここに帰ってくると思います
それで
この問いを僕の周りの人に聞いてみるとみんなは
やっぱり受けにで自動的そして後ろ向きな意見がいっぱい帰ってきたんです
現状の日本の教育っていうものを考えてみると
受け身なんですよね
学校の授業にしてもだんだん年齢が上がっていけばいくほど
先生が一方的にバーッと教科書の内容をしゃべってそれをノートにとって
でテストんでるよとか
そういう授業が多くなっています
予備校なんてなおさらですねただ別に僕はそういうのを否定してる訳じゃありません
僕は学校大事ですそういうものを否定しているわけじゃないんですがそういった
1本的な家し押し付ける受け身な教育そういうものがあるからこそ
やっぱり
学ぶがはもう
とっても受け身的な後ろ向きな社会になってしまうじゃないか
そんなふうに思うんです
ただそんなことを考えてみれば簡単な話なんです
みんな気づいています
簡単にそれを解決する方法はもっと能動的に学ぶ期待というものを増やすだけのこと
です
で実際に国も動き出しています2020年度から
アクティブラーニングと呼ばれる能動的な学びというものを取り入れた学習っていう
ものを実施するよう学習指導要領の改定の準備が進んでますそんな感じで国の人たちも
動いているし学校の人たちも
グループガッシー行ったりとかいろんなことをして能動的な学びというものを考えるし
てるんです
でも僕は多分
イクラー
国が動いても教育委員会の人たちが頑張った分
能動的な学びというのは本当には実現できないじゃないかなと思うんです
それはなぜか
それは授業っていうのは
教える側がいて鳴り出すものではないからです
授業っていうのは授業を受ける人
生徒がいて初めて成り立つものなんです
だから受ける人たち需要を受けて学ぶ側が能動的にならなくては意味がない
この僕がやっている高校生教室という場所は高校生が教えて
高校生が学びます
そしていろんな形で授業に参加するんです
参加するっていうことが一番能動的な学びだと思っています
そしてここの場所で授業を作り上げるっていう経験
もちろんそれでもいいんですがそれを学校の授業でも応用してほしいなってことを持っ
ています
学校の授業も自分が参加して初めてこの授業が成り立っている
そういう考え方をするだけできっと授業っていうものはもっと能動的なものになると
思います
僕はこれから多分一生をかけてこの労働的な学びというものをみんなができるように
この高校生教室みたいな手法もあると思っています
みんながもっと能動的に自分が作っているっていう意識を持って授業とか学校とかそう
いうものを作っていくそういう人を増やしていけるような
まあ人間になっていければなということを考えているんです
んですね
この僕が入っている能動的に学ぼうという話は別に何も勉強に限ったことじゃないなと
思っています
この話をするとある人が登場するんですけれど
僕の周りにがとっても将来の事に対して何となく前向きに考えることができない人がい
たんです
まあいろんな理由があったんですけど
そのしたよく言うのは
んのやりたいことがないんだよねっていうことを僕によく行っています
なんだか
人生生き生きしていない感じだ
だけど
勉強はものすごくできて僕よりもはるかにいいしていけるといいですね
僕はそれを見ててなんか悔しかったですぼくこんないろいろなことをやってるのになん
であいつの方ができるんだみたいな感じで悔しかったんですけれど
曲
なんで下民なっちゃうんだろうがあってことを考えたときにやっぱり
自分が社会をこれから作っていくっていう
ちょっとした考え方が変わるか変わらないのかなのかな
猫とちょっと思ったんです
それで僕と一緒に高校生教室にしてもそうだし
いろんな話をその一つはしていきました
で
だんだんだんだんなんですけどちょっとずつ
その人は
自分のことっていうのを将来の事っていうのも前向きに考えるようになっていった
ただ別に
さっきの入ってるみたいに能動的になるっていう話なんですけど別に能動的になるため
には
夢を持ってほしいとか将来こういう風になりたいっていうことを必ず言えるようになっ
て欲しいとかそういうことじゃないんです
別にそれはずっと探しでもいい
ただ将来の事っていうを
ちょっと前向きに捉えてほしかった
それだけのことです
だんだんその人は自分って
あ幸せだなあとかそういうことをポロッと言うようになりました
僕はもうそのことがすごく嬉しかったんです
それは
咽頭これからの先将来世界っていうものを一緒になって前向きに考えてくれる仲間が
見つかったから
僕はその事が本当に嬉しかっ
って言って喜んでいるところにちょうどその人はあと3週間くらいすると日本からい
なくなるんですけれども僕が帰ってそのことで僕が後ろ向きになっちゃいそうなんです
けど
冗談として
やっぱり
何事に対しても
能動的になり前向きに考えるって言うだけできっと世界というのは良くなる
で前向きな世界を作るために僕たちは今
学ぶんだと思います
そしてだからこそ学ぶ場所っていうのは前向きな存在であるべきだなって僕は思って
いるんです
これから先僕はさっきも言ったんですが
もっとみんなが前向きに学ぶことができる社会をつくりたい
そんなことを思っています
ただ別にこれは僕ひとりでできることではないなぁってことを感じています
皆さんと一緒に皆が前向きに学ぶことができる授業
学校っていうのを作って
そこから
みんなが前に気に1 p ている社会というものを作っていければなということを僕は
今考えているところです
今日はありがとうございました